on passe donc à la chronique économie de
ce 25 avril est clair ce soir on parle
de coiffure tout à fait aujourd'hui on
sait d'économie c'est très sérieux
c'est de l'économie ont parlé du mahf
même un cycle un peu étrange mais que
tous les ouvriers connaissent il s'agit
du concours du meilleur apprenti de
france
un concours ouvert à toutes les
disciplines artisanale et qui revêt du
coût des formes très variées avec nous
sur ce plateau
nous nous recevons un jeune apprenti
coiffeur qui a passé ce concours
dimanche dernier dylan présage bonsoir
tu as 16 ans tu habites magny les
hameaux et tu vas nous raconté notamment
comment s'est passé ton épreuve
de la semaine dernière chez venue
accompagnée de sa mère françoise presa
bonjour et notre troisième invité et
isabelle de fausses responsable du dion
du concours toutes disciplines
confondues pour les yvelines est
également professeur d'esthétique au
centre de formation de versailles c'est
ça mon soir bonsoir
alors pour commencer on va tout de suite
clore le suspense à propos des résultats
de dylan et je vous propose de découvrir
comment il s'est débrouillé durant ce
concours un reportage réalisé avec julie
rocha soares et elodie moines le grand
jour est arrivé pour dylan
après des mois d'entraînement le magnet
quoi passe le concours du meilleur
apprenti départementales et régionales
nous le retrouvons pour sa troisième et
dernière épreuve la coiffure de soirée
le jeune coiffeur et laura son modèle se
met en place et déjà les consignes sont
lancés dylan concentrés écoutent à peine
et prépare son matériel un regard sur la
montre et le top départ est lancé
c'est parti pour 50 minutes de création
capillaire ses deux premières épreuves
la mise en plis techniques et la coupe
couleur se sont plutôt bien déroulées au
matin alors dylan et serein pas stressé
justement il a l'air plutôt confiant
ambiance studieuse dans la salle tous
les concurrents se concentrent sur leurs
coiffures dylan mis sur le volume dans
cette épreuve
mais les cheveux dolora lui joue des
tours ils n'arrivent pas à les plaques
et convenablement un coup de brosse par
ci un coup de peigne par là le jeune
apprenti tente de rattraper le coup
finalement avant même la fin de
l'épreuve il range ses affaires sans
cacher sa déception
il ya des choses qui vont pas comme une
attente populaire dans la salle
d'accueil là où on a reçu ce matin
place maintenant à la notation les jurys
étudie chaque coiffure
ici on juge la technique mais surtout la
créativité et l'esthétique avec un
système de points au final
il pourra donc y avoir plusieurs
meilleurs apprentis un certain nombre de
points donne la médaille de bronze puis
l'argent et enfin l'or et avec cette
médaille d'or régionale la qualification
pour la finale nationale
pendant que dylan attend les
délibérations en famille on a tenté de
savoir si sa prestation avait été à la
hauteur
un quart sont prometteurs
là des idées maintenant sur le plan
technique que c'est normal il n'a qu'un
an et demi de profession donc un an et
demi de l'apprentissage
mais s'il continue dans ce bois là ça
sera bien cette longue journée touche à
sa fin et avec elle le verdict tant
attendu les premiers appelés ont obtenu
la médaille départementale de bronze
mais le temps passe et dylan on y croit
mais quelques minutes plus tard
ouais
dylan a décroché la médaille d'or
départementale et la médaille d'argent
régionale
une belle récompense je m'attendais pas
à ça ils terminent quatrièmes ex-aequo
sur 20 pour sa famille c'est la
consécration d'un gros investissement
je suis très fier de lui quoi très
content parce que va tous tout ce qu'il
a fait ça a payé quoi c'est et comme lui
il a la passion de sabin je vois là
c'est très contente pas alors dylan ce
qu'on verra un sujet tu n'es tu n'y
croyais pas finalement pas du tout je
pensais que j'avais tout raté niveau du
chignon mais faut croire que oui
déjà les eaux apprécié alors recevoir
ses deux médailles d'or médaille d'or
départementale médaille d'argent
régionale qu'est ce que qu'est ce que ça
représente pour toi mais d'entraînement
c'est quelque chose quand même
mais beaucoup d'investissement c'est
aussi une fierté pour vous j'imagine
mais c'est une grande fierté on est tous
fiers de lui et bien sûr mais c'est vrai
qu'on s'attendait pas c'était mes mariko
médaille les médailles seront remises
pour le département
le 27 mai à la chambre de métiers des
yvelines et pour la médaille régionale
ce sera à paris le 21 juin
dans les salons de la légion d'honneur
si vous déjà répété oui c'est la
médaille c'est une médaille de meilleur
ouvrier de france
voilà donc c'est à ce titre que je
m'occupe de ce concours pour les
yvelines du concours des meilleurs
apprentis
oui justement vous avez cette médaille
d'or en 2001 de mire et le concours de
meilleur apprenti c'est géré par
l'association des meilleurs ouvriers de
france tout à fait d'un concours qui a
été qui est proposé par l'association
des meilleurs ouvriers de france
c'est un concours qui existe depuis 1985
qui est qui se pratique à un niveau
national depuis 2000 et qui correspond à
un petit peu à l'esprit du concours
meilleur ouvrier de france
voilà alors c'est ce goncourt justement
il sert
il y à quoi sert-il pour les jeunes eh
bien ça sert à leur donner le goût du
travail le goût de l'effort à promouvoir
leur métier également on voir leur
travail
et puis peut-être espère-t-on qu'un jour
ils se dirigeront aussi vers le concours
de meilleur ouvrier de france
parce que les le concours du meilleur
apprenti le concours du meilleur ouvrier
c'est forcément un plus dans la carrière
d'un baril mais tout à fait oui voilà ça
sera très certainement à plus sur son cv
les l'employeur voit quand même qu'il ya
un goût justement de l'effort un goût du
travail
les employeurs sont sensibles à ce tout
à fait vous vous êtes professeur
d'esthétique oui je crois qu'une de vos
élèves déjà gagné ce concours nous ils
plusieurs élèves j'ai plusieurs élèves
donc en esthétique qui ont remporté la
médaille une médaille d'or nationale et
qui avait été repris du coup parlera par
l'employeur ah bah oui les employeurs
sont très satisfait très content et le
mettre en avril le mettre là justement
dans leur entreprise ils ont raison
juste d'autres supports soient également
que ça va pouvoir aider pour la suite
tu as déjà des idées de 2 des taux futur
ouais je pense que ça va m'aider vu que
je veux travailler sur les plateaux je
pense que forcément on va choisir
quelqu'un qui ne médaille au niveau des
meilleurs ouvriers plutôt que quelqu'un
qui ment n'a pas là pour la suite
après ton apprentissage tu as déjà une
idée je crois de ton prochain donc lier
bas pour le bébé je vais aller dans un
welsh et un autre patron d'accor alors
et finalement de ceux dans ce concours
donc on l'a vu il ya plusieurs médailles
dix-huit participants finalement il ya
trois médailles d'or régionale
et puis les autres qui se décline il n'y
a pas qu'un seul gagnant
non non c c'est comme pour le concours
du meilleur ouvrier de france en fait il
peut y avoir plusieurs meilleurs
apprentis après c'est une question de
notes
voilà entre
entre je sais plus 14 et 16 on aura une
mais deux oui une médaille d'or
départementale ensuite ça sera une
médaille d'argent puis une médaille d'or
ensuite seuls les médailles d'or et
d'argent pourront se présenter aux
régionales puis seuls les médailles d'or
régionale pour ans se présentait en
finale nationale en finale nationale
donc ce qui explique que si plusieurs
participantes un bon niveau atteignent
ont de bonnes notes
ils pourront être récompensés et tu n'as
pas eu je pense à ta note finale de l'us
open il a gagné au concours des
meilleurs ouvriers de france on est où
on n'est pas prêt il n'y a pas de
classement bien passé le concours
plusieurs fois oui on peut alors pour le
meilleur le concours du meilleur
apprenti en fait il est réservé à des
jeunes de moins de 21 ans et qui n'ont
pas encore le ca paix ou le bac
professionnel c'est un concours e voilà
pour des jeunes de niveau 5 qui sont en
cours de formation pour un c ap donc ils
peuvent éventuellement le passé en
première année c'est ap mais bon lors
des conseils parce qu'ils ont pas un
acquis suffisants donc en règle générale
on leur conseille en deuxième année
monties redouble ce qu'on leur souhaite
pas passer mais voilà non après on peut
pas après ils peuvent se diriger sur sur
d'autres concours tu as envie de passer
d'autres plaisirs plus comme les
olympiades
des meetings mais moi j'avais pensé
après me retire usées vers les meilleurs
ouvriers avaient à la suite est
d'ailleurs en ce moment c'est nous
sommes en période d'inscription voilà
inscriptions passerez meilleur et le
meilleur ouvrier de france jusqu'à fin
septembre
voilà dans les yvelines il ya eu
j'imagine d'autres candidats dans
d'autres disciplines puisque ce n'est
pas forcément fermé à la coiffure mais
pour tous les métiers meilleur apprenti
ville avant de parler oui oui oui mais
tout à fait donc sur le cfa nous avons
par exemple une médaille d'or en
prothèse dentaire
sinon nous avons eu des débats des
barmans qui ont été récompensés sur les
yvelines les métiers du service
également là en restauration arts de la
table et du service voilà donc nous
avons dix médailles à ce jour et à
chaque fois c'est des épreuves très
varié très variés oury bah en fonction
fonds saab est donc des concours ce
qu'on dit en loge en loge voilà c'est un
relais de la coiffure et l'esthétique
donc c'est une épreuve où finalement les
personnes viennent et travaille en
direct on va dire et puis finalement il
yad'autres d'autres concours pour le
meilleur apprenti où ils viennent avec
eux quelque chose de déjà prêt mais
voilà ils vont devoir préparer une pièce
qui sera évaluée également à plusieurs
niveaux départemental régional et
national
tout à fait donc par exemple les
tailleurs sûr que les tailleurs sur
pierre ou les ébénistes enfin bon voilà
ce genre de métier il fabrique une pièce
qui est évalué ensuite non pas des jurys
constitués de meilleur ouvrier de france
de professionnels de professeurs
formateurs
bien sûr pour conclure juste un petit
mot peut-être sur tt coach quiconque
hommes suivis pendant des mois
ça a été un gros investissement
finalement pour eux et puis
aussi pour eux mais pour les parents
aussi oui en fait c'est surtout lui
quoique c'est vrai qu'on voulait les
remercier les scotch parce que bon c'est
quand même bien qu'ils s'investissent
aussi à vouloir aider ben comme la un
apprenti qui voudraient et puis ils sont
là ils l'aident le conseil donc c'est
ainsi que le salon le dimanche ex
prévoit la maison était là bon c'est
vrai qu'on les remercie beaucoup pour ça
et puis dylan voilà lui étaient très
motivés et nous on était voilà avec lui
quoi elle félicitations à 3